From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。
It was like taking kids out to the jungles of Vietnam and dropping them off, knowing they were going to be shot at. It was as if winning was a foreign thing to them. It's as if it had been bred into them that they could never, ever win.
这就像把孩子们带到越南的丛林里，把他们扔在那里，明知他们会被枪击一样。就好像获胜对他们来说是一件很陌生的事。就好像他们骨子里就认定，他们永远、永远不可能赢。
What we're talking about here is football-- high school football. After two seasons, this fall Leo Paur stepped down as head coach of the team at Carbon High School, a couple hours outside Salt Lake City. They have the longest losing streak in the state of Utah. 25 games, nearly three full years of losses. This year they scored only three touchdowns. Last year half the team quit during the season. The team's so bad they're mocked in the hallways of their own school.
我们这里谈论的是橄榄球——高中橄榄球。经过两个赛季后，利奥·帕尔今年秋天辞去了犹他州盐湖城外几小时车程的卡本高中橄榄球队主教练的职务。他们拥有犹他州最长的连败纪录。25场比赛，将近三年的失利。今年他们只触地得分三次。去年赛季中途，半支球队的人都退出了。这支球队太烂了，以至于在他们自己的学校走廊里都遭到嘲笑。
Yeah. We're definitely-- we got a joke every day, every day in class.
是的，我们肯定……我们每天在课堂上都会听到笑话。
Yeah. We're not, like, looked upon. We're more like--
是的，我们没被当回事。我们更像是……
Laughed about.
被人取笑。
Running back Andrew Salazar, linebacker Damien Olson, and defensive guard Max Meisner have all played on the team three years. That is, they've all been there on the worst team in the state though this entire losing streak.
跑锋安德鲁·萨拉萨尔、线卫达米恩·奥尔森和防守截锋马克斯·迈斯纳已经在队里打了三年球。也就是说，在整个连败期间，他们一直身处这支州里最差的球队中。
There's a lot of kids out there that think it's funny to make fun of the team instead of support us.
有很多孩子觉得嘲笑我们球队比支持我们更有趣。
Yeah, they tease us.
是的，他们嘲笑我们。
They tease you, what do they say?
他们取笑你们，他们都说什么？
Just joking around against our rivals and saying, like, how many points are you going to beat us by and stuff.
就是开我们对手的玩笑，说我们要赢他们多少分之类的。
Why do you guys even try, because you're going to lose, no matter what you do.
为什么你们还要努力呢，因为不管你们怎么做，反正都会输。
Makes you kind of feel like an outcast. I don't know. Just because you get picked on.
让人觉得有点像被排挤了。我不知道。就因为你被人欺负。
Just so I have a sense of what they were like to watch on the field, tell me about some of their worst moments. Tell me about a particularly bad player, bad moment that you remember.
为了让我了解他们在场上的表现，告诉我一些他们最糟糕的时刻。告诉我一个你记忆中特别糟糕的球员或糟糕的时刻。
Last year against [? Althemont ?] School. Much smaller than Carbon. We would punt the ball. The wind took it naturally. it landed behind my punter. I mean, we lost yardage on a punt.
去年对阵阿尔特蒙特学校。他们比卡本小得多。我们要弃踢球。风自然地把它吹偏了。球落在了我弃踢手身后。我的意思是，弃踢反而丢了码数。
Against Juan Diego last year, we had played ten minutes. And Juan Diego, who were the state champions that year, had not scored against us. That was a great time. And my brother, who was helping me coach at the time, came up and said, this would be the first time we've gone an entire quarter without being scored on. And I said, well, there's two minutes left.
去年对阵胡安·迭戈时，我们已经打了十分钟。胡安·迭戈是那年的州冠军，他们还没能从我们手里得分。那是一段美好的时光。当时协助我执教的兄弟走过来对我说，这将是我们第一次在一整节比赛中没有失分。我说，还有两分钟。
They went and they scored four touchdowns in two minutes. It was very disheartening.
他们随后在两分钟内触地得分四次。这非常让人灰心。
Four?
四次？
Four. Yep. Two offensive and two intersections. Ran back. So I told my brother not to open his mouth again when that happens.
四次。是的。两次进攻得分，两次拦截回攻。所以我告诉我的兄弟，下次这种情况发生时，千万别再开口了。
The real question when you're down this far is, how to keep getting up and going out there, game after game? What do you say to yourself? How do you keep going? How do you keep a team going?
当你陷入如此低谷时，真正的问题是，如何一次又一次地站起来，去参加下一场比赛？你对自己说什么？你如何坚持下去？你如何让一支球队继续前进？
For Coach Paur, the answer could not be more straightforward.
对帕尔教练来说，答案再简单不过了。
I always, always had to make them believe the they could win. It was hard. Especially after two years of losing every game. But yeah. I had to make them believe that miracles do happen. That the movies you watch where the young man or the young woman overcomes all of the odds, that that is possible. Even though it's a long shot.
我总是，总是必须让他们相信他们能赢。这很难。尤其是在连续两年输掉所有比赛之后。但是的。我必须让他们相信奇迹确实会发生。你在电影里看到的那些年轻人克服重重困难的故事，那是可能实现的。尽管希望渺茫。
Wouldn't it be better, I asked the coach, in a game where the team is totally outmatched, to set a goal that they could actually make? Like let's just get one touchdown on the board in the first half. Something like that.
我问教练，在球队完全处于劣势的比赛中，设定一个他们真正能实现的目标会不会更好？比如，我们上半场先拿到一次触地得分。类似这样的。
That made no sense to him at all. You have to believe you'll win, he said.
这对他来说根本没有意义。他说，你必须相信你会赢。
And teams do come from behind. Impossible miracle victories happen. Like remember last year's Kentucky Derby? The horse that won was such a long shot that the Sports Illustrated writer assigned to the race never even bothered to find out about him before the race. He'd lost 31 of his previous 32 races. At 50 to 1 odd, he was the longest long shot ever to win the Derby in over a century. Newsday published a preview of the race where it told this horse to just stay in the barn.
而且球队确实会实现反超。不可能的奇迹胜利确实会发生。还记得去年的肯塔基德比吗？获胜的那匹马机会太渺茫了，以至于《体育画报》负责这场比赛的记者在比赛前甚至懒得去了解它。它之前的32场比赛输了31场。50比1的赔率，它是百年来赢得德比最不可能的黑马。《新闻日报》在赛前预览中甚至建议这匹马待在马厩里别出来。
As the field turns for home, top of the stretch, it's still Join In The Dance with a tenuous lead--
随着赛场转入终点直道，依然是“加入舞蹈”处于微弱领先优势——
If you watch this race on YouTube-- and you should, it's incredible-- the horse that's going to win is called Mine That Bird. And he is so far behind that halfway through the race, you see all the other horses-- they're in a pack-- and then this huge empty space, and then way behind that space is Mine That Bird. Then he picks up speed, he catches up to the pack, and it's not until the final stretch that he passes every other horse and gets out in front. It all happens so fast that the announcer doesn't even have time to say his name until it's nearly over.
如果你在YouTube上观看这场比赛——你应该看，非常精彩——那匹将要获胜的马叫“矿鸟”。它落后得那么远，以至于比赛进行到一半时，你会看到所有其他马都在一个集团里，然后是巨大的空档，再后面才是“矿鸟”。然后它加速，追上了马群，直到最后直道它才超过每一匹马冲到最前面。这一切发生得太快，解说员在比赛快结束时甚至还没来得及喊出它的名字。
Mine That Bird now comes out to take the lead as they come down to the finish. And it's spectacular! Spectacular upset! Mine That Bird has won the Kentucky Derby, that impossible result here!
“矿鸟”现在冲出来占据了领先，他们冲向终点。太壮观了！壮观的冷门！“矿鸟”赢得了肯塔基德比，在这里创造了不可能的结果！
That's how he did it. The jockey, Calvin Borel, said, I road him like a good horse. Coach Paur believes in that, too.
他就是这样做的。骑师卡尔文·博雷尔说，我像驾驭一匹好马一样驾驭它。帕尔教练也相信这一点。
Well, that is very applicable. You have to make the kids believe that they can win.
嗯，这非常适用。你必须让孩子们相信他们能赢。
So when you do that, and you tell the team that they can win, and then they lose, is the disappointment worse, because they had--?
所以当你这样做，告诉球队他们能赢，结果他们还是输了，那种失望感会不会更严重，因为他们有了……？
Absolutely not. I mean, what should I tell them? Look, go out and do a good job losing? Go on out, lose, and then you'll feel happier when the game's over? Absolutely not. I'd never do that. I'd be a fool to do it.
绝对不会。我的意思是，我该告诉他们什么？听着，去打一场漂亮的败仗吧？走出去，输掉比赛，然后比赛结束后你会感觉更开心？绝对不会。我绝不会那样做。那样做我就太傻了。
It works so well, Couch Paur even convinces himself. At the start of his second season he told a reporter, quote, "This is going to be an outrageous thing for me to say, and I'm really cautious, because we lost every game by an average of 37 points last year, and the year before that we only won two games, and the year before that, I don't even know that they won any games. But I think I can contend for the region championship. I really do."
这招很管用，帕尔教练甚至说服了自己。在他执教的第二个赛季开始时，他告诉记者，引用他的话：“这对我来说是一个惊人的说法，我很谨慎，因为去年我们每场比赛平均输了37分，前一年我们只赢了两场，再前一年，我甚至不知道他们赢过比赛没有。但我认为我可以争夺分区冠军。我真的这么认为。”
Yep. I said that. I believed it at the time.
是的。我说了。当时我相信这一点。
Would you go into each game thinking, like, OK, this could be the one where we would turn it around?
你是否会带着“好吧，这可能是我们翻盘的一场”这样的想法进入每场比赛？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I've always thought that.
是的，我一直这么想。
Yeah.
是的。
And did you guys have in your head this fantasy of, like, here's what it would be, like, if you would win a game, and here's what would happen?
你们脑子里有没有幻想过，如果你们赢了一场比赛，会是什么样？会发生什么？
Every day, every day.
每天，每一天。
I actually had one about ALA, when we went into the half.
关于ALA，我们半场时确实有过一个念头。
Going into halftime against ALA, Carbon was having their best game of the season. They were just one touchdown behind.
对阵ALA的中场休息时，卡本队打出了他们本赛季最好的一场比赛。他们只落后一个触地得分。
You know, I pictured it, you know, we're going to come out fired up, and we're just going to kick the ball, and we'll go down there and stop them, probably cause a fumble down there at our, like, 20, and I'm running it in, you know? And then kicking it off again, and stopping them, forcing a punt. Throwing a nice long ball to somebody down in the end zone, and give a 30 yard pass for a touchdown, and then we'd be up, so then we'd go for two, and we'd get it, and then we'd just keep increasing the points like that.
你知道，我幻想过，我们要充满激情地出场，开球，冲下去阻止他们，可能在我们的20码线附近导致他们掉球，然后我带球跑进去，你懂吗？然后再开球，阻止他们，逼迫他们弃踢。给终点区的人抛一个漂亮的远距离长传，30码达阵，我们就领先了，然后我们争取两分转换并成功，接着我们就这样不断扩大比分。
I've always pictured, like, the students walking in the halls, you know, patting you on the back, being like hey, you know, nice win.
我一直幻想，学生们走在走廊里，拍着你的背说，嘿，漂亮的胜利。
Yeah, good game.
是的，好球。
Saying good job, you know, or whatever.
说干得好，之类的。
Today on our show, stories of long shots. We have two stories where somebody is up against very bad odds. And each of these stories raises the question, are you really better off believing that you're the miracle team who's going to come out from behind, that you're going to defy all predictions, that you are Mind That Bird?
今天在我们的节目中，讲述关于不被看好的故事。我们有两个关于有人在极度不利的情况下奋力拼搏的故事。每一个故事都提出了一个问题：你是否真的最好相信自己是那个能从劣势中崛起的奇迹球队，你将打破所有预测，你就是“矿鸟”？
Act one is about somebody battling the biggest state in the country and its governor. Act two is about somebody battling a house and his own father, which in a certain way is a lot harder. Stay with us.
第一幕是关于某人对抗全国最大的州及其州长的故事。第二幕是关于某人对抗一栋房子和他自己的父亲，从某种程度上来说这要困难得多。请继续收听。
Act One. Hasta La Vista, Maybe.
第一幕：再见，也许吧。
Most places, if you're serving a life sentence with the possibility for parole, you go before a parole board. And if they find you suitable for release, that's it. You get out.
在大多数地方，如果你被判终身监禁且有机会获得假释，你会出现在假释委员会面前。如果他们认为你适合释放，那就是这样了。你可以出狱。
But there are three states, California, Maryland, and Oklahoma, where there is one more step. The governor in those three states gets a chance to look at the parole board's decision and, if he or she wants, overturn it. In all three states, over the years, this has evolved to the point where very few prisoners actually get released. No governor wants some ex-con that he's let out commit another crime that's going to get blamed on him. As a result, in California's prisons, the lifer population has jumped from 4,800 back in the 1980s, when governors started viewing these cases, to 31,000 this year.
但有三个州，加利福尼亚、马里兰和俄克拉荷马，多了一个步骤。这三个州的州长有机会审查假释委员会的决定，如果他或她愿意，可以推翻它。在这三个州，多年来，这已经演变到很少有囚犯真正获得释放。没有州长愿意因为他释放的某个前罪犯再次犯罪而受到指责。结果，在加州的监狱里，无期徒刑犯人的数量从20世纪80年代州长们开始审查这些案件时的4800人，激增至今年的31000人。
Nancy Mullane has been following a dozen California prisoners to see what happens when the governor reviews their cases. She has this story of one of those man who finds out that he's eligible for parole, and then even though he knows the odds are against him, he kind of has to believe that he has a shot. He finds it hard not to get excited for something that will probably never happen. Here's Nancy.
南希·穆兰一直在追踪十几名加州囚犯，看看当州长审查他们的案件时会发生什么。她讲述了其中一名男子的故事，他发现自己有假释资格，尽管他知道胜算不大，但他还是不得不相信自己有机会。他发现很难不对一件可能永远不会发生的事情感到兴奋。这是南希的报道。
I met Don Cronk inside San Quentin State Prison. He was serving 25 years to life with the possibility of parole for first degree murder. By the time I met him, Don had been in prison for 27 years, and had already gone before the parole board six times. Each time the board turned him down and declared that he was unsuitable for parole because of the seriousness of his crime. The commissioners even commended him for his accomplishments and his perfect record in prison, but they denied him parole. That was until his seventh parole hearing.
我在圣昆廷州立监狱见到了唐·克朗。他因一级谋杀罪被判处25年至终身监禁，并有机会假释。我见到他时，唐已经在监狱里待了27年，并已经六次出现在假释委员会面前。每次委员会都拒绝了他，并宣布由于他的罪行严重，他不适合假释。委员们甚至称赞了他的成就和他在狱中完美的表现记录，但他们还是拒绝了他的假释。直到他的第七次假释听证会。
OK, Commissioner Eng, we're back on record.
好的，恩委员，我们重新开始记录。
This is tape from Don's parole board hearing. On November 18, 2007, the commissioners found Don suitable for parole.
这是唐的假释委员会听证会的录音。2007年11月18日，委员们认定唐适合假释。
--is suitable for parole, and was not--
……适合假释，并且没有……
I didn't know that she had said it.
我不知道她说了那句话。
Don Cronk was stunned.
唐·克朗惊呆了。
That's right where they usually say "not suitable." And when she said it so quickly, I didn't hear that she said "suitable." And she's reading on and on, and no indication in it. So I looked at my attorney to see if-- you know, I expected to look at him and he'd have thumbs up and smiling, and he was flabbergasted. And so I couldn't get any indication from him what she said. And so she went on to read for several minutes. And then when she got done with that part, she went on to speak about my suitability and what was going to happen next.
通常他们会说“不适合”。当她那么快地说出来时，我没听清她说的是“适合”。她接着读下去，没有任何暗示。所以我看着我的律师想……你知道，我期待着看他一眼，他会竖起大拇指微笑，但他却目瞪口呆。所以我无法从他那里得到任何关于她说了什么的暗示。她接着读了几分钟。当她读完那部分后，她开始谈论我的适应性以及接下来会发生什么。
And that's when it hit me, and I just broke down. I just sobbed. The officers got me a box of Kleenex. You know, for almost 27 years, I've been waiting for this. And it's kind of unbelievable.
就在那一刻，我崩溃了，我放声大哭。警官给了我一盒纸巾。你知道，近27年来，我一直在等待这一刻。这简直令人难以置信。
So I was in shock, essentially. I didn't really hear anything else she said. And then it was over, and I was leaving. I was walking out the door. Almost a free man.
所以我基本上处于休克状态。她说的其他话我都没听进去。然后就结束了，我就离开了。我走出大门。几乎是一个自由人了。
The operative word here being "almost." In California, after the parole board recommends for release, there's a 120 day period. During that time, the parole board staff in the state capital verifies everything in the inmate's record, their behavior while they've been in prison, and where they would work and life if they get out on parole.
这里的关键词是“几乎”。在加州，假释委员会建议释放后，有一个120天的期限。在此期间，州首府的假释委员会工作人员会核实囚犯记录中的所有内容、在狱中的表现，以及如果获得假释后他们将在哪里工作和生活。
On the 121st day, their file goes to the governor's desk. The governor then has 30 days to either approve or overturn the board's recommendation. For Don, that meant he would learn his fate on April 11, 2008.
在第121天，他们的档案会送到州长办公桌上。州长有30天的时间批准或推翻委员会的建议。对唐来说，这意味着他将在2008年4月11日得知自己的命运。
It was hard to get a read on Don's chances. On the one hand, he'd been the very definition of a model prisoner. He'd taken college classes and earned an associate's degree. He was enrolled in a program to become a certified drug and alcohol abuse counselor. He worked in the chapel and didn't have any writeups from violence or bad behavior, and he had a positive psychiatric report. Even one writeup for smoking a cigarette just one time in three decades can keep you from getting parole in California.
很难判断唐的机会。一方面，他是模范囚犯的定义。他上过大学课程并获得了副学士学位。他参加了一个成为认证药物和酒精滥用咨询师的项目。他在教堂工作，没有任何暴力或不良行为的记录，还有一份积极的精神病学报告。即使在加州，仅仅因为在三十年内抽过一次烟，也可能让你无法获得假释。
On the other hand, the statistics we're not on Don's side, and he knew it, Of the 6,000 lifers that go before the parole board each year, Don was one of only 3%, about 200 prisoners, found suitable for parole. Of those 200, Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger would reverse 75% of the parole board decisions. So in the end, only 50 prisoners a year would actually be released.
另一方面，统计数据对唐不利，他也知道这一点。每年有6000名无期徒刑犯出现在假释委员会面前，唐是仅有的3%（约200名囚犯）被认定适合假释的人之一。在这200人中，阿诺德·施瓦辛格州长会推翻75%的假释委员会决定。所以最终，每年只有50名囚犯真正获得释放。
Schwarzenegger's predecessor, Governor Gray Davis, was even more severe. He overturned 99% of all paroles recommended by the board.
施瓦辛格的前任，格雷·戴维斯州长更为严厉。他推翻了委员会建议的所有假释中的99%。
Don had seen other lifers who had been found suitable by the parole board, guys whose records were as clean as his, get their hopes up only to have their parole denied on the last day by the governor.
唐见过其他被假释委员会认定为适合、记录和他一样干净的人，却在最后一天被州长拒绝了假释。
I recorded this next conversation inside San Quentin in early January, two months after the parole board found him suitable to be released. Don's a white guy in his earl 50s, neatly kept with a close-cropped beard, receding hairline, and wire-rimmed glasses.
我于1月初在圣昆廷记录了下一次对话，这是在假释委员会认定他适合释放两个月后。唐是一个50出头的白人，留着整齐的短胡须，发际线后移，戴着细框眼镜。
I'm fully aware that the governor, you know, this doesn't mean I'm going in April. And I'm aware of that. And so you, again, it's kind of like going to the hearings. You keep that hope, you keep that prayer, but you temper it with reality. You look at the statistics, and they're not good. They're not good. And so you're trying to balance all that, and then carry on your normal routine, your normal life.
我完全意识到，州长……这并不意味着我四月份就能出去。我意识到这一点。所以，这就像参加听证会一样。你保持那种希望，你保持那种祈祷，但你要用现实来缓和它。你看看统计数据，它们不好。它们不好。所以你在努力平衡这一切，然后继续你正常的日常生活。
The first maybe even two weeks, it hadn't even sunk in. But I'd be in my cell now, and I'd be watching television, and I wouldn't be having a thought about it, really. And then I'd see something, and it would trigger that, and it was almost like I was given a shock. And I was like, oh. I could be doing that. I could be doing that soon.
头两周可能甚至还没反应过来。但现在我会在牢房里，看电视，其实根本不会去想它。然后我会看到什么东西，它会触发那个想法，就像我受到了电击。我想，哦。我可能正在做那个。我可能很快就能做那个了。
Does it make it any more difficult to be incarcerated once you know somebody's found you suitable?
一旦知道有人认为你适合，在狱中生活会变得更困难吗？
What I've noticed, the biggest thing I've noticed is, and it was almost like turning on a light-- I've become intolerant now. For some reason, the meals I've been eating for all these years, and the noise, and the smell, and the lines, and all that-- suddenly, I've just become aware that this is crap. This is no way to-- how in the hell have I been doing this all these years?
我注意到，我注意到最大的一点是，这就像打开了一盏灯——我现在变得不能忍受了。出于某种原因，这些年来我吃的饭，噪音、气味、排队等等——突然间，我意识到这全是垃圾。这根本不是……这么多年来我是怎么熬过来的？
Some of the things that happen in prison is just mean or ridiculous, doesn't make sense. Terrible. It's terrible. I don't know how I've lived like this. And it's not over yet.
监狱里发生的一些事情简直卑劣或荒谬，根本说不通。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。我不知道我是怎么活成这样的。而且还没结束。
I understand that if the governor denies me, it's not personal. He doesn't know me. He himself isn't saying, well, that Don Cronk, I'm not letting him go. It's not. I'm just a number and a statistics on a piece of paper. And whatever the political wind is that day, I'm either denying him or I'm letting him go. That's really it. And even if it's a denial, he doesn't know. It's, I'm a life inmate. I committed a murder. We're either releasing him today, or we're not.
我明白，如果州长拒绝我，那不是针对个人的。他不认识我。并不是他自己在说，哦，那个唐·克朗，我不让他走。不是的。我只是一张纸上的数字和统计数据。无论当天的政治风向是什么，我要么拒绝他，要么让他走。真的就是这样。即使是被拒绝，他也不知道。我是无期徒刑犯。我犯了谋杀罪。我们今天要么释放他，要么不释放。
The governor assesses each of these cases individually.
州长会逐一评估这些案件。
This is Justice Peter Siggins. He was Governor Schwarzenegger's legal affairs secretary from 2003 three to 2005, and he counseled the governor on hundreds of these parole decisions. I ran past him Don's theory that these decisions have nothing to do with the merits of the cases, that they're political decisions.
这是彼得·西金斯法官。他曾于2003年至2005年担任施瓦辛格州长的法律事务秘书，他为州长提供了数百起此类假释决策的建议。我向他提出了唐的理论，即这些决定与案件本身无关，纯粹是政治决定。
When I was legal affairs secretary, and people used to say to me, well, the governor is responding politically, and you are being political about a decision to keep a prisoner in prison-- part of a governor's job is to be responsive to the constituents who elected him. The fact that the governor thinks a lot of people would be upset if this person got out of prison-- it is a governor paying attention to the preference of a large constituency of California. And that's what governors do.
当我担任法律事务秘书时，人们常对我说，州长是在做政治回应，你也在把留住囚犯当作政治行为——州长的工作的一部分就是要对选他出来的选民负责。州长认为如果这个人出狱，很多人会感到不安——这是州长在关注加州广大选民的偏好。这就是州长们所做的。
We generally did parole consideration matters every couple of weeks. I'd meet with him once every couple of weeks for that purpose. And a typical calendar would be anywhere between 12 and 20 cases at each sitting. And he and I would sit down and discuss every case, yes.
我们通常每几周处理一次假释考虑事宜。我每两周会为了这个目的和他开一次会。典型的日程每次坐下来会处理12到20个案件。我和他会坐下来讨论每一个案件，是的。
I can say that I don't think Governor Schwarzenegger, and certainly I didn't, I don't think we entered upon the responsibility with a predetermined inclination to go one way or the other with these decisions.
我可以肯定地说，我不认为施瓦辛格州长，当然我也没有，我不认为我们在承担这些决策责任时，带着预设的倾向往哪个方向走。
The governor was given the power to overturn parole board decisions in 1988 by California voters. It was the same year as the Willy Horton controversy, where the governor of Massachusetts, Michael Dukakis, was blamed for a convicted murderer getting out of prison on a furlough program and committing assault, armed robbery, and rape.
州长被赋予了在1988年由加州选民推翻假释委员会决定的权力。那是威利·霍顿争议发生的同一年，当时马萨诸塞州州长迈克尔·杜卡基斯因一名被定罪的谋杀犯在休假项目中出狱并实施攻击、武装抢劫和强奸而受到指责。
California's law was intended to hold the governor accountable in this kind of high profile case. It later became a constitutional amendment, though no one knew how often the governor would reverse a parole order.
加州的法律旨在让州长对这类高调案件负责。它后来成为了一项宪法修正案，尽管没有人知道州长会多频繁地推翻假释令。
I don't know that anybody gave that much thought, seriously. I don't remember a huge concern over the passage of the law at the time.
我不认为有人认真地想过这个问题。我不记得当时法律通过时有什么巨大的担忧。
Jeanne Woodford worked at San Quentin when the law went into effect, and became warden of the prison in 1999. In 2004, Governor Schwarzenegger made her the head of the California prison system, which she did for two years.
珍妮·伍德福德在该法律生效时在圣昆廷工作，并于1999年成为该监狱的典狱长。2004年，施瓦辛格州长任命她为加州监狱系统负责人，她担任了两年。
You know, I don't know that inmates believed, or even practitioners believed, that the governor would reject as many cases as they did when it initially passed. I remember some concern, but still people believing that there would be a fair process.
你知道，我不认为囚犯，甚至从业者，认为州长会在法律刚通过时拒绝那么多案件。我记得有一些担忧，但人们仍然相信会有一个公平的过程。
It just didn't turn out that way. It ended up where governors were turning down just every case.
结果并不是那样。最后变成了州长们拒绝了每一个案件。
Woodford agrees with the prisoners on this issue. She thinks the governor should listen to his parole board. It costs the state over $100 million a year for the parole board to thoroughly review each case, and it finds very few lifers suitable for release.
伍德福德在这一点上同意囚犯们的看法。她认为州长应该听取假释委员会的意见。假释委员会每年花费州政府超过1亿美元来仔细审查每个案件，而它发现适合释放的无期徒刑犯很少。
So should we be afraid of Don Cronk? How bad was his crime?
那么我们应该害怕唐·克朗吗？他的罪行有多严重？
In 1980, Don was 25 years old, and a pretty normal guy. He was living in Sacramento and working as a service manager in a furniture store.
1980年，唐25岁，是个相当普通的人。他住在萨克拉门托，在一家家具店担任服务经理。
What I did-- I was a young man and I was introduced to cocaine. And I liked it a lot. I liked it a real lot.
我所做的……我当时是个年轻人，我接触了可卡因。我非常喜欢它。我真的非常喜欢。
Now, I say that because I had tried almost every other kind of drug. I'm allergic to marijuana. I don't like alcohol. I'll drink it, a few beers, but I do not like that drunk feeling. Crank is too intense. Heroin makes you sick. LSD is a recreational thing once in a while when you were a kid going to concerts with Mickey Mouse ears. Other than that, I didn't really have any fascination with addiction, so I thought I was fine.
现在，我这么说是因为我几乎尝试过所有其他种类的毒品。我对大麻过敏。我不喜欢酒精。我会喝几杯啤酒，但我真的不喜欢那种醉酒的感觉。冰毒太猛了。海洛因让你生病。LSD是一种偶尔尝试的休闲东西。除此之外，我并没有真正对成瘾着迷，所以我以为我没事。
When I was introduced to cocaine, I instantly fell in love with it. And, because at that time, cocaine was very expensive, and guess who was doing it the most? Wealthy people. So I associated it with the Porsches and the people like my boss, millionaires, doctors. That's who was doing it. And so I thought, this is great. Then I was told it wasn't addicting.
当我接触到可卡因时，我立刻爱上了它。而且，因为当时可卡因非常昂贵，你猜谁用得最多？有钱人。所以我把它和保时捷，和我老板那样的人，百万富翁，医生联系在一起。这就是谁在用它。所以我以为，这很棒。然后我被告知它不会上瘾。
Then I started dealing it, and getting deeper away from the beautiful people into the ugly people. And I met some associates, like-minded. Two of them were ex-felons. I wasn't an ex-felon. But they were charismatic. They were just not bad guys, really.
然后我开始贩卖它，并从美好的人群中越走越远，走向糟糕的人群。我遇到了一些志同道合的同伙。其中两个是前罪犯。我不是。但他们很有魅力。他们真的不算坏人。
Long story short, we ended up using more than we were selling. Now we owe the connections and the dealers. And that's not good. And so my new found friends had done armed robberies in the past, and so hey, we could do some robberies. So we did a couple robberies. And no one was hurt. We got some money and all that.
简短地说，我们最终用掉的比卖掉的还多。现在我们欠了联系人和毒贩钱。这可不好。所以我的新朋友过去做过武装抢劫，所以嘿，我们可以去抢劫。于是我们做了几次抢劫。没人受伤。我们得到了一些钱，诸如此类。
And then the night of the crime that I'm here for, it was to be a robbery. And we had some inside information, there would be a lot of money and jewels.
然后是我就在此服刑的那个犯罪之夜，那是一次抢劫。我们得到了一些内幕消息，会有很多钱和珠宝。
And long story short is, we were going to this man's home. Wait for him. He would come in. We'd tie him up, take his briefcase and the money and leave. We had the masks, we had the tape, we had the whole nine yards.
简短地说，我们要去那个人的家里。等他。他进来。我们把他绑起来，拿走公文包和钱，然后离开。我们有面具，有胶带，我们准备好了一切。
Well, we were going to have the element of surprise and surprised him as he came in. But it didn't work that way. He got in, and when I walked out of the kitchen and saw Mr. Allen standing in the open door, my mind was going, how the hell did he get in here? Because we had a warning system that was supposed to give us the alert so we could hide and get in position.
好吧，我们要利用突袭的因素，在他进来时让他措手不及。但事情没按计划进行。他进来了，当我从厨房走出来看到艾伦先生站在敞开的门口时，我在想，他妈的他怎么进来的？因为我们有一个警告系统，本该给我们提示，这样我们就可以躲起来并就位。
He's standing there, and while my mind is like-- I'm shot. It was that he emptied the gun that quickly. And next thing I know, I'm on the floor. I'm in the corner. And I reached in my pocket, and shot right through my coat. He died instantly.
他站在那里，当我的大脑还在……我开枪了。枪里的子弹很快就打光了。接下来我知道的是，我在地板上。我在角落里。我伸手去口袋，直接隔着大衣开了枪。他当场死亡。
Unbelievable. I couldn't do that again. I couldn't re-enact that. Seconds. it all took place in a few seconds. And you can't undo it.
难以置信。我不可能再做一次。我无法重演那个。几秒钟。这一切都在几秒钟内发生。你无法挽回。
It's just horrible, addicted thinking, immature thinking, selfish thinking, greedy thinking. Nobody else mattered but us. But was the intent or in my mind to murder somebody? No. Even in that state, I wouldn't have willfully or deliberately gone that far.
这只是可怕的瘾君子思维，不成熟的思维，自私的思维，贪婪的思维。除了我们，没有别人重要。但在我的脑海里，我有意图或动机去谋杀某人吗？没有。即使在那种状态下，我也不会蓄意或刻意走到那一步。
And so it's just a horribly unfortunate turn of events that I'm responsible for. I caused it.
所以这只是一个极其不幸的事件转变，我对此负责。我造成了它。
I'd love to have the governor's ear for 20 minutes. I really think if he sat down across from me and we could just talk, and he could question me, and he could see the change-- you know, they look at us on paper, black and white. Well, it's just like reading the newspaper.
我真希望能有20分钟的时间让州长听听。我真的认为如果他坐在我对面，我们可以谈谈，他可以质疑我，他可以看到我的改变……你知道，他们只在纸面上看我们，非黑即白。好吧，那就像读报纸一样。
You wake up this morning, you look at the news, and there was a crime committed. Oh, a shooting in Oakland, someone died. And it may tell about it, and you think, oh, that's horrible. That's terrible. They ought to catch that guy and put him away.
你今天早上醒来，看新闻，发生了一起犯罪。哦，奥克兰发生了一起枪击事件，有人死了。报道可能告诉你这件事，你想，哦，那太可怕了。那太糟糕了。他们应该抓住那家伙把他关起来。
Well, that's what my newspaper read 27 years ago, but today they're reading it and it's just like it just happened. Oh, this guy did that thing. Oh, he shouldn't be released.
嗯，那是27年前我的新闻里写的内容，但今天他们读起来，就像刚刚发生的一样。哦，这家伙干了那种事。哦，他不应该被释放。
But it was 27 years ago. I've paid. I've done all I can. I can't change those facts.
但那是27年前的事了。我已经付出了代价。我已经做了我能做的一切。我无法改变那些事实。
As the 150 days of review pass and Don gets closer to his April 11 date, his anxiety grows. He tells me he has hallucination-like dreams where he wakes in the middle of the night to the sound of a phone ringing, imagining it's the phone call telling him he's been approved for release. He sees it as just another sign from the universe that he's getting out. He tries relaxation and breathing techniques to fight the constant tension.
随着150天的审查过去，唐离4月11日的期限越来越近，他的焦虑与日俱增。他告诉我，他会有幻觉般的梦，在深夜醒来时听到电话响，想象那是告诉他已获准释放的电话。他将其视为宇宙发出的另一个信号，预示着他要出去了。他尝试放松和呼吸技巧来应对持续的紧张感。
Throughout all of this, Don's main support is his girlfriend, Kathleen.
在这期间，唐的主要支持是他的女朋友凯瑟琳。
We started out as friends, and it evolved into a deeper, deeper, deeper relationship.
我们从朋友开始，然后发展成一种更深、更深、更深的关系。
Kathleen met Don 18 years ago while visiting a friend in San Quentin. Since then, her continuous presence in Don's life actually strengthens Don's case as a candidate for parole. The review process takes into account stable relationships, and Kathleen has even written a letter to Governor Schwarzenegger on Don's behalf to show he has a place to live and emotional support if paroled
凯瑟琳18年前在圣昆廷探望朋友时认识了唐。从那时起，她在唐生命中的持续陪伴实际上加强了唐作为假释候选人的理由。审查过程会考虑稳定的关系，凯瑟琳甚至代表唐写了一封信给施瓦辛格州长，以证明他如果获得假释，有地方住并且有情感支持。
Like everyone in Don's life' Kathleen knows the odds are against the governor letting him out. But she can't stop herself from imagining what his first week on the outside would be like.
像唐生活中的每个人一样，凯瑟琳知道州长让他出去的胜算很小。但她无法克制自己去想象他出狱后的第一周会是什么样子。
I'm going to have a bunch of food. I'm going to ask him many questions. I'm saying, dinner's ready, whatever. You know? Did you have a particular thing you want to eat fine? Otherwise-- in other words, I think he's going to be so overwhelmed that I'm not really giving-- I'm not asking him what do you want to eat, or what do you want to do. I'm just telling him. That way it's one less thing that he has to do. He's going to be overwhelmed enough. I'm going to say-- you know, it's like somebody's on rote. I'm going to say, OK, no. You sit here. Come on. We're having this.
我准备了一大堆食物。我会问他很多问题。我会说，晚餐准备好了，随便什么。你知道吗？你有没有特别想吃的好东西？否则……换句话说，我想他会不知所措，所以我不会真的给……我不会问他你想吃什么，或者你想做什么。我只是告诉他。这样他需要做的事情就少了一件。他已经够不知所措了。我会说……你知道，这就像有人在背诵课文。我会说，好的，不。你坐在这里。来吧。我们吃这个。
And then as he calms down and gets used to everything, then he can say, you know, I really want some barbecued chicken. Great!
然后当他冷静下来，习惯了一切，他就可以说，你知道，我真的想吃烤鸡。太棒了！
On Don's 149th day of waiting, the day before the governor issues his decision about Don's parole, I visit Don in the chapel. He's visibly excited and nervous.
在唐等待的第149天，也就是州长做出唐的假释决定的前一天，我到教堂看望唐。他明显很兴奋也很紧张。
27 plus years of prison could be just over with the signing of a pen. Just like that. So you go from here, and they just-- now you're there. That quick.
27年多的牢狱生涯可能就在这一笔之下结束了。就是这样。所以你从这里走出去，他们就……现在你在那里。就那么快。
You know, there was like a 12 year period when no one was going. No one was going. Didn't matter who you were, what you were.
你知道，有大约12年的时间，没有人出狱。没有人。不管你是谁，你是干什么的。
But now this last, I'd say, 18 months, almost every guy I know is gone. I don't know. I'm spiritual. I believe God's hand has been on all this. And this is, I don't know. This is, I think it's going to happen. I just think it's going to happen. It's just this sense that I'm going to go. And we'll find out tomorrow.
但现在这段时间，我想说，过去18个月，我认识的每个人都出去了。我不知道。我很虔诚。我相信上帝的手一直在指引这一切。我觉得……这要发生了。我只是觉得要发生了。这只是一种我要出去的感觉。明天我们就知道了。
The next day, Friday, April 11, 2008, I drive to San Quentin. An assistant to the warden, Lieutenant Sam Robinson, is the one who gets the faxes from the governor's office, and he's the one who delivers the news to the prisoners, good or bad. He's waiting for me in the warden's office, and I notice some papers turned face-down on his desk.
第二天，2008年4月11日星期五，我开车去圣昆廷。典狱长的助理萨姆·罗宾逊中尉是负责接收州长办公室传真的人，也是负责将消息传达给囚犯的人，无论好坏。他在典狱长办公室等我，我注意到他桌上有一些面朝下放的纸。
How you doing? You want to know or you want to be surprised?
你好吗？你想知道结果，还是想感到惊喜？
Oh my God. You got it. Did it just come?
天哪。你拿到了。刚收到的吗？
Mmhm.
嗯。
About an hour ago we received the notification from the warden in regards to Mr. Cronk's board parole hearing in which the board granted him parole. The governor has reversed the board's decision, and at this time we'll be going inside and delivering the news to Mr. Cronk.
大约一小时前，我们收到了典狱长关于克朗先生假释听证会的通知，委员会授予了他假释。州长推翻了委员会的决定，现在我们将进去把这个消息告诉克朗先生。
God. I don't know. My face is not a good face. I don't lie well. I know.
上帝。我不知道。我的表情不太好。我不擅长撒谎。我知道。
That's why I was saying. Do you want me to let you know, or?
所以我才说。你想让我告诉你，还是？
Well, first just your voice sounded a little optimistic, and I thought maybe, maybe. that there was something in the tone of your voice.
嗯，首先你的声音听起来有点乐观，我想也许，也许……你的语调里有些什么。
Think they're all listening and waiting?
你认为他们都在听，都在等吗？
Yeah. The guys were calling me earlier today saying, hey, you heard any word on Cronk? You know, with the hope that one of their brethren is going home.
是的。这些伙计们今天早些时候给我打电话说，嘿，你有克朗的消息吗？你知道，怀着他们的兄弟要回家的希望。
We're walking down to 371 North, which is Mr. Cronk's cell.
我们正走去371北区，那是克朗先生的牢房。
Hello? Mr. Cronk?
你好？克朗先生？
Yes?
是的？
How are you?
你好吗？
Well, I don't know. I've been sick to my stomach all day.
嗯，我不知道。我整天胃里都不舒服。
Well, here's the word.
好吧，消息在这儿。
I can tell because it's too thick.
我看得出来，因为它太厚了。
I can tell because it's too thick, he says. If he were to be released, Lieutenant Robinson would just be holding one sheet of paper, not a half dozen, like he is.
他说，因为它太厚了。如果他能被释放，罗宾逊中尉只会拿着一张纸，而不是像他现在这样拿着半打。
Yeah. What can you do, you know? But I thank you for coming by.
是的。你能怎么办呢，你知道吗？但我谢谢你过来看我。
Nancy, how are you?
南希，你好吗？
I'm all right. How are you?
我还好。你好吗？
I'm disappointed. Very disappointed. But what are you going to do. You know? It's just been-- if I'd have found out early this morning it would have been-- but we've just been all but throwing up all day. You know? And the later it got, the worse they knew the news was, so.
我很失望。非常失望。但你能怎么办呢。你知道吗？只是……如果我今天早上早点知道它会是……但我们整天都难受得快吐了。你知道吗？越晚，他们越知道消息很糟糕，所以。
But it's been, I'm exhausted. I'm drained. And I just got to shut down for a minute. I just want to be left alone, you know? Yeah. Yeah, I really just want to be left alone.
但这已经……我精疲力竭了。我被掏空了。我得关机一会儿。我只想一个人待一会儿，你知道吗？是的。是的，我真的只想一个人待一会儿。
A week later, I ask to go back inside San Quentin to see how Don is doing. He no longer looks like a man about to be free. He looks like a man in prison. He's gray, deflated. He tells me he can't believe how high he let his hopes get in the last few weeks against his better judgment.
一周后，我要求回到圣昆廷看唐怎么样了。他看起来不再是一个即将自由的人。他看起来像个囚犯。他脸色灰暗，垂头丧气。他告诉我，他无法相信在最后几周，违背自己更好的判断，让自己抱有了多么高的期望。
I was feeling almost giddy. Like, hey, this may really happen. This could really-- it should happen. You know? There's no reason why it shouldn't happen.
我当时感觉简直飘飘然。就像，嘿，这可能真的会发生。这真的能……它应该发生。你知道吗？没有理由它不该发生。
You know. Then you add the governor. It's his last go-around. The state's in budget crisis. You know, overcrowding, the Feds are knocking on the door. I mean, you look at all these elements and you think, you'd be a fool not to let a guy go that the board's saying go! You know, save them 40 grand a year, or whatever.
你知道。然后你加上州长。这是他最后一次任期了。州里有预算危机。你知道，人满为患，联邦政府在敲门。我的意思是，你看看所有这些因素，你觉得，如果你不放一个委员会说可以放的人，那你就太傻了！你知道，每年还能给他们省下4万美金什么的。
But so I talked myself into it, that I was going home. I knew better. But I set myself probably the last three weeks. I wanted to believe it that I felt that I was going to go.
但我还是说服了自己，我要回家了。我知道得更好。但我设下了……可能最后三周。我想相信这一点，我感觉我要出去了。
And then Kathleen. You know, I just-- my main concern was her. And so even though, like, she wanted to go buy things and get things prepared and ready, I would always say, well, you know, maybe we shouldn't do that yet. Let's wait and see. You know, the odds are way against me.
还有凯瑟琳。你知道，我只是……我主要的担心是她。所以即使她想去买东西，准备好一切，我总是说，嗯，你知道，也许我们还没必要那样做。让我们等等看。你知道，胜算非常不利于我。
So she didn't go too far out there. But in her heart, of course, she was already seeing the next day, you know, in our future.
所以她没太超前。但在她的内心深处，当然，她已经在展望第二天了，在我们的未来里。
But when we were able to get together and see each other-- I called the visiting room and I told the visiting room officer what had happened. I had said, you know, listen, by the way, I was denied parole by the governor. And I said, look. If Kathleen comes, if she breaks down, or if I break down, if we're crying or if she's a little clingy for a few minutes, there's nothing wrong. It's just this news.
但当我们能够聚在一起见面时……我给探视室打了电话，告诉探视室警官发生了什么。我说，听着，顺便说一下，我的假释被州长拒绝了。我说，看。如果凯瑟琳来了，如果她崩溃了，或者我崩溃了，如果我们哭了，或者她黏着我几分钟，那没什么大不了的。这只是这个消息。
And sure enough, when Kathleen came, as soon as she got in, as soon as I took her in my arms, she just, I had to hold her up. She just broke. She just sobbed.
果然，凯瑟琳来了，她一进来，我一抱住她，她就，我不得不扶住她。她崩溃了。她只是放声大哭。
But I really thought that was a kind act. They could've said, well, we don't care. The rules are the rules and you get two seconds and that's it.
但我真的觉得那是一种善举。他们本可以说，嗯，我们不在乎。规则就是规则，你只有两秒钟，就是这样。
Don says that back in 1984, when he first got to San Quentin, he could barely hold it together. San Quentin, he says, was like Vietnam back then. It was violent, with stabbings and shotguns going off all the time, and he didn't see how he'd last.
唐说，早在1984年，他刚到圣昆廷时，他几乎无法坚持下去。他说，圣昆廷当时就像越南。那里充满暴力，经常发生捅人事件，霰弹枪响个不停，他不知道自己怎么能活下去。
But emotionally, he says, this year was harder. it wasn't easy for him to get and keep a perfect disciplinary record, never to have one fight, or even one incident, in 27 years. He followed the rules. He did everything they said he should. Why put him through the charade of doing that, he asked? Why put him in front of a parole board over and over, having them examine his record, if this is where it leads?
但在情感上，他说，今年更难。要获得并保持完美的纪律记录，在27年里从未打过一次架，甚至连一次事故都没有，对他来说并不容易。他遵守了规则。他做了他们说他应该做的一切。他问，为什么要让他经历这种表演？为什么要一次又一次地把他放在假释委员会面前，让他们审查他的记录，如果结果是这样的话？
Why have the board? Why have those experts trained in law enforcement and all different sectors put their best effort forward? They don't grant parole often. So for them to do so, this must be an exceptional case. And then the governor takes it and denies it.
为什么要设立委员会？为什么要让那些受过执法和各个领域培训的专家展现他们的最佳努力？他们不常授予假释。所以他们这样做，这一定是个例外情况。然后州长拿走并拒绝了它。
So what's the point? You know? Well, then, what was all that about? Why don't we just go to the governor?
那么意义何在？你知道吗？嗯，那这都是为了什么？为什么我们不直接去找州长？
Normally for lifers like Don, the next step is simply to wait, go before the parole board again, and hope for a better outcome the next time.
通常对于像唐这样的无期徒刑犯，下一步只是等待，再次出现在假释委员会面前，并希望下次能有更好的结果。
But Don got amazingly lucky. In August 2008, the California Supreme Court ruled in favor of another lifer, Sandra Lawrence, saying that the governor could not deny parole to someone simply because his or her original crime was so terrible. Life with the possibility of parole, the court said, means exactly that. There has to be a real possibility for parole if a prisoner can show he or she has been rehabilitated.
但唐运气好得惊人。2008年8月，加州最高法院对另一名无期徒刑犯桑德拉·劳伦斯做出了有利于她的裁决，称州长不能仅仅因为某人的原始罪行非常可怕就拒绝假释。法院说，有假释机会的终身监禁就是那个意思。如果囚犯能够证明他或她已经改过自新，就必须有真正的假释可能性。
Don's case was like Sandra Lawrence's. The governor had written that he was reversing Don's parole because of the seriousness of his crime.
唐的案件和桑德拉·劳伦斯的案件一样。州长写道，他推翻唐的假释是因为他的罪行严重。
In January of 2009, Don was brought to a courthouse in Sacramento, the county of his original crime, where a superior court judge said his case was exactly like the Lawrence case.
2009年1月，唐被带到萨克拉门托的一个法院，那是他原始犯罪的县，高等法院法官说他的案件和劳伦斯案完全一样。
She read the law and said, "This man fits this perfectly." And then the attorney general just said, the woman, Heather Heckler's her name, and she just started to make a case, and she just said, "We don't have anything."
她读了法律说，“这个人完全符合这个条件。”然后总检察长只是说，那个女人，希瑟·赫克勒是她的名字，她开始申辩，她只是说，“我们没什么可说的了。”
The attorney general admitted, had to admit to her, we don't have anything. The governor had nothing and we don't have anything either. And the judge said, well, why are we here then? Because we just disagree with Lawrence. And she goes, so you're here because you disagree with current law. And she said, yes. The judge said, well, I'd like to close this hearing. It was over! It was over. And we won.
总检察长承认，不得不承认，我们什么都没有。州长什么都没有，我们也没有什么。法官说，那我们在这干什么？因为我们不同意劳伦斯案。她说，所以你们在这里是因为你们不同意现行法律。她说，是的。法官说，好吧，我想结束这次听证会。结束了！结束了。我们赢了。
Three months later, April 13, 2009, a year and two days after the governor reversed the parole board decision, Don was released from San Quentin.
三个月后，2009年4月13日，在州长推翻假释委员会决定一年零两天后，唐从圣昆廷获释。
In January 2010, Don's been out for eight months. He and Kathleen are living together and seem happy. He was doing construction work at a mausoleum near San Quentin and his commute every day took him over the Richmond-San Rafael bridge. At a certain point at the top of the arched bridge, he could see the prison where he lived more than half of his life. It was always emotional. "My family in there," he told me one day when we took the drive together. "They're still in there."
2010年1月，唐已经出狱八个月了。他和凯瑟琳住在一起，看起来很幸福。他在圣昆廷附近的一个陵墓做建筑工作，每天的通勤路都经过里士满-圣拉斐尔大桥。在拱桥顶部的某个点，他可以看到他度过半生岁月的监狱。这总是充满情感。“我的家人在里面，”我们一起开车时他有一天告诉我。“他们还在里面。”
Nancy Mullane. She's writing a book called Life After Murder and putting together a two-hour radio documentary on other lifers in Don's situation. Her reporting was funded by the Soros Justice Media Fellowship. She and we repeatedly contacted Governor Schwarzenegger's office, inviting his comments for this story, but didn't get a response.
南希·穆兰。她正在写一本书，叫《谋杀后的生活》，并正在制作一部关于唐那种情况的其他无期徒刑犯的两个小时电台纪录片。她的报道是由索罗斯司法媒体奖学金资助的。她和我们多次联系施瓦辛格州长办公室，邀请他为这个故事发表评论，但没有得到回应。
Coming up-- a story where no one is going to mention the Vietnam War in some random, passing reference. I know we're two for two stories so far. We've got one more shot in today's show. We can do it! We can do a Vietnam reference-free story, I swear.
接下来——一个不会在某些随机、顺带的提及中提到越战的故事。我知道我们到目前为止两个故事都提到了。今天节目里还有一个机会。我们能做到的！我发誓，我们可以做一个没有越战背景的故事。
That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
那是一分钟后的事，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Long Shots. People facing such long odds it's hard to know if they're doing the right thing when they hope against hope that they're going to come out on top.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，《黑马》。人们面临着如此大的胜算，很难知道当他们在希望渺茫中仍抱有希望时，他们做的是否正确。
We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two. House Dutiful.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕：忠诚的房子。
The way that anything happens in this world is that somebody gets a vision in their head for how they want something to go, or how they're going to make something, and then they run at it with all their might, and people tell them that it's hopeless, and the person doesn't care, it's just in them, right? Which is either really smart or really dumb.
这个世界上任何事情的发生，都是因为某人在脑子里产生了一个愿景，关于他想要事情如何发展，或者他要如何做成某事，然后他用尽全力去奔跑，人们告诉他那是绝望的，而这个人不在乎，它就在他们心中，对吧？这要么真的很聪明，要么真的很笨。
Wells Tower went through this with a house. A house he decided, against everybody's advice, to fix up.
威尔斯·托尔就是这样经历了一栋房子的事情。一栋他不顾所有人建议，决定修理的房子。
Several years ago, while I was walking through my father's kitchen, I noticed a beetle dying on the countertop. "Hey," I said to my father, who was sitting a few feet away at the kitchen table, doing something on his computer, "there's a beetle dying here. "Mmhm," he said, without taking his eyes off the screen.
几年前，当我走过父亲的厨房时，我注意到案台上有一只甲虫正在死去。“嘿，”我对坐在几英尺外餐桌旁、在电脑上做事的父亲说，“这里有一只甲虫要死了。”“嗯，”他说，眼睛没有离开屏幕。
I walked by again later and noticed that ants were streaming out of a dark little groove in the windowsill above the kitchen sink. "Hey, it looks like you've got some ants living in your windowsill," I said. "Might want to caulk that up or something." "Yep," he said again.
我后来又经过时，注意到蚂蚁正从厨房水槽上方窗台的一个阴暗小缝隙里流出来。“嘿，看起来你窗台上住了一些蚂蚁，”我说。“你可能想把它填上之类的。”“是的，”他又说。
A few hours passed, and then I noticed that the ants were trooping down past the sink and over the Formica to where the dead beetle lay. Before long, the ants had dismantled it entirely and were carrying the beetle piecemeal back into the windowsill "OK Dad," I said. "Now the ants have chopped up the beetle and they're toting it into your wall." "See?" he said, without looking up. "The system works."
几个小时过去了，我注意到蚂蚁正排队经过水槽，越过福米卡台面，来到那只死甲虫所在的地方。没过多久，蚂蚁就把它完全拆解了，并把碎片搬回窗台。“好了爸爸，”我说。“现在蚂蚁把甲虫切碎了，正把它搬进你的墙里。”“看见了吗？”他说，没有抬头。“系统在运作。”
In the years my father has owned this house, a small brick ranch in central North Carolina with small, lightless rooms, entropy has been his handyman and groundskeeper. When my family first moved here 30 years ago, the surrounding acres held a horse pasture, a flourishing orchard, a scuppernong arbor, a vegetable garden, and a large, healthy lawn.
在我父亲拥有这栋房子的这些年里，这是一栋位于北卡罗来纳州中部的小型砖砌牧场式平房，房间又小又暗，熵一直是他的勤杂工和看守。30年前我家第一次搬到这里时，周围的土地拥有牧马场、茂盛的果园、圆叶葡萄架、菜园和一大片健康的草坪。
The average person would have been pleased to luck into a piece of land so well-tended. But according to my father's philosophy, the garden and the rest of it were troublesome. They required mowing, pruning, fertilizing.
普通人会很高兴能幸运地拥有这样一块精心照料的土地。但根据我父亲的哲学，花园和其他一切都是麻烦。它们需要割草、修剪、施肥。
So my father worked his "system" on these difficulties, And in time vines strangled the fruit trees, the grape arbor rotted and collapsed, and the pasture became a forest of scrub saplings. The burden of their maintenance was unshouldered for good.
所以我父亲在这些困难上运用了他的“系统”，久而久之，藤蔓绞杀了果树，葡萄架腐烂倒塌，牧场变成了灌木丛林。维护它们的负担永远地被卸下了。
My father's campaign of deliberate neglect got into full swing after my parents divorced when I was six years old. He stopped mowing the lawn. He cancelled garbage collection, preferring to burn the household refuse in the driveway. Nonflammable junk, derelict hibachis, spent brake shoes, crates of rusted wood screws filled the garage so densely that you wouldn't want to set foot in there without knowing the date of your most recent tetanus booster.
我父亲蓄意疏忽的运动在我六岁父母离婚后全面展开。他停止了割草。他取消了垃圾收集，宁愿在车道上烧掉家庭废弃物。不燃的垃圾、废弃的炭火盆、用过的刹车蹄、装满生锈木螺丝的板条箱填满了车库，以至于如果你不知道上次破伤风加强针的日期，你根本不想踏进那里。
On summers home from college, my brother and I would try living in the house, usually with girlfriends, in the hope of making the place feel like a home. Our relationships usually ended after these little experiments in cohabitation, and Dan and I learned that it was fruitless to hope too grandly about transforming the place. And also that it was best to be careful about whom we exposed to the house.
在从大学回家的暑假里，我和弟弟会尝试住在房子里，通常带着女朋友，希望让这个地方感觉像个家。我们的关系通常在这些小小的同居实验后结束，丹和我学到了对改变这个地方抱有太大的希望是徒劳的。而且最好小心点，不要把谁带到这里来。
After Dan and I left home for good, the house decayed speedily. The brush grew denser. The furnace broke and my father declined to repair it for the better part of a decade. Year round, a stack of pine logs stood in the center of the living room floor, shedding bark and teeming with insect life. I stored a couch at the house one time, and when I went back to retrieve it nine months later, a skein of ivy had crept in through the window and wrapped itself around the armrest. Once I stopped by the place and saw what appeared to be a family of minnows swimming in the toilet.
丹和我彻底离开家后，房子迅速腐朽。灌木丛变得更密。炉子坏了，我父亲近十年都拒绝修理它。终年，一堆松木原木立在客厅地板中央，掉落着树皮，虫子滋生。有一次我把一张沙发存在这栋房子里，九个月后我去取回时，一簇常春藤已经从窗户钻了进来，缠绕在扶手上。有一次我顺道去那里，看到厕所里似乎游动着一群鲦鱼。
The house's decline was so depressing to my brother and me we began avoiding the place entirely.
房子的衰败让我和弟弟感到如此沮丧，我们开始完全避开这个地方。
In my 31st year, after a decade of moving from place to place, I decided to go back to live in my hometown. For years I'd nourished a fantasy of building a home of my own, and my mother, who owned a couple dozen acres across town, had agreed to sell me a sizable plot.
31岁那年，在辗转各地十年后，我决定回到家乡生活。多年来，我一直怀揣着建造自己房子的梦想，拥有城里几十英亩土地的母亲也同意卖给我一大块地。
It was to be the opposite of my father's house. A timber frame post and beam house with cathedral ceilings, plenty of windows and skylights, and a minimum of interior walls. But it would be many months in the building, and my father, who was teaching in Europe at the time, suggested that I move into his house in the interim.
它将是我父亲房子的反面。一栋带大教堂天花板、充足窗户和天窗、内部墙壁最少的木结构房。但这需要好几个月的时间来建造，当时正在欧洲教书的父亲建议我在过渡期间搬进他的房子。
My father had remarried and for the last five years, he'd been living with my stepmother 45 minutes away. I didn't relish the idea of living at the old house, but it would only be for a few months. "And when you get back," I told my father, "maybe we can work on fixing up the house." "Yes," he said. "I'd like that."
父亲再婚了，过去五年他一直和后母住在45分钟路程外。我不喜欢住在老房子的主意，但那只会是几个月。“当你回来时，”我告诉父亲，“也许我们可以着手修理房子。”“是的，”他说。“我喜欢这样。”
I'd seen  the place in worse shape. The wood pile was now gone from the living room and the furnace had been replaced, though the garage was still impassable. My first week back, I ventured out there, and a possum spring from behind a pile of garbage and hissed at me. I scampered back into the house. The first time I ran the bathroom faucet, a moth fluttered from the drain.
我见过这地方更糟糕的样子。木柴堆现在已经不在客厅了，炉子也换了，尽管车库仍然无法通行。回来的第一周，我冒险走进去，一只负鼠从一堆垃圾后面窜出来对我嘶嘶叫。我跑回屋里。第一次打开浴室水龙头时，一只飞蛾从下水口飞了出来。
The grass needed mowing though the yard was a good deal smaller than it used to be. Much of what had once been lawn had become a young forest of junk trees-- sweetgum and rangy loblolly pines-- were, in turn, being choked to death by a rapacious wisteria infestation that spanned a good half acre. The weeds rose past my knee. The'd evidently gotten the best of my father's lawnmower, which was resting in the shade of a holly bush.
草需要割，尽管院子比过去小多了。曾经是草坪的大部分已经变成了由杂树组成的幼林——甜胶树和细长的火炬松——反过来又被蔓延开来的贪婪紫藤扼杀，跨越了半英亩。野草长过了我的膝盖。显然它们已经打败了我父亲的割草机，它正躺在冬青树的阴影下。
I went to the hardware store bought a new one, a shiny Briggs & Stratton with an earnest red finish. Mowing was slow, unrewarding work. I could make only a foot or two of progress at a time before the weeds wound around the blade and choked the engine off. Rotten tree limbs lay buried in the thatch. I plunged the mower into tussocks of thistle, hip-high. I tangled with great bullwarks of honeysuckle.
我去了五金店买了一台新的，一台闪亮的Briggs & Stratton，有着诚实的红色涂装。割草是很慢、吃力不讨好的工作。我每次只能推进一两英尺，杂草就会缠住刀片并让引擎熄火。腐烂的树枝埋在茅草里。我把割草机扎进齐腰高的蓟草丛中。我和巨大的忍冬藤蔓纠缠在一起。
Sometimes the mower would shriek and shutter, which meant I'd found some forgotten artifact in the lawn. I laid bare bricks, axe heads, an old rusted ratchet set, a rotting telephone pole, shreds of T-shirts, shards of a jelly jar I remembered drinking from as a kid. The lower blades flung a constant hail of found object shrapnel in my face. I shut my eyes and loathed the lawn and loathed myself for coming back to this place.
有时割草机会尖叫和颤抖，这意味着我在草坪上发现了一些被遗忘的文物。我裸露出的砖块、斧头头、一套生锈的棘轮工具、一根腐烂的电线杆、T恤碎片、我记得小时候喝水用的果酱罐碎片。底部的刀片不断向我的脸上抛射一串串发现物碎片。我闭上眼睛，厌恶这片草坪，也厌恶自己回到这个地方。
A few days later, my brother stopped by the house to show me his new pickup truck. "It's a bad ass truck," he said. "Four wheel drive. It's got a carriage-welded class four trailer hitch." He repeated this phrase like an incantation. "Carriage-welded, class four, trailer hitch."
几天后，我弟弟顺道过来给我看他的新皮卡。“这是辆超酷的卡车，”他说。“四轮驱动。它有一个托架焊接的四级拖车挂钩。”他像咒语一样重复着这句话。“托架焊接，四级，拖车挂钩。”
We opened a couple of beers and walked around the house. I was already slipping into the old trap of imagining the house's potential, and I made the mistake of mentioning this to my brother. "Think about what you could do with this place," I said. "All you would have to do is knock down about 60% of the walls and put in some new windows. Maybe make an addition out of the garage. This could be a fantastic place to live."
我们开了几瓶啤酒，围着房子转。我已经陷入了想象房子潜力的旧陷阱，我犯了个错误，把它提给了弟弟。“想想你能在这个地方做什么，”我说。“你只需要敲掉大约60%的墙壁，换上一些新窗户。也许把车库扩建一下。这可以是一个生活的好地方。”
My brother nodded. "Yep," he said. "I guess the first thing you probably want to do is go ahead and drop a nuclear bomb on it, for starters. You know, when dad dies, we're going to have to haul a huge dumpster out here and basically throw the whole place away. What you really need to do is bulldoze it, subdivided it, run a cul-de-sac through here. It'd be a cash cow."
弟弟点了点头。“是的，”他说。“我想你可能想做的第一件事就是直接给它扔一颗原子弹，作为开端。你知道，爸爸去世后，我们将不得不拖一个巨大的垃圾箱来这里，基本上把整个地方扔掉。你真正需要做的是推倒它，细分，修一条死胡同。这会是一棵摇钱树。”
Then we went and sat in my brother's old bedroom, which was crowded with mail crates full of extension cords and dead tennis balls. He said, "I sure do hate this place, but I guess, in a way, that's a good thing. I mean, it was hating this house so much that made me go out and get houses of my own."
然后我们去坐在弟弟的旧卧室里，里面挤满了装满延长线和废旧网球的邮件箱。他说：“我确实很讨厌这个地方，但我猜，某种程度上，这是件好事。我的意思是，正是因为太讨厌这栋房子，才促使我出去拥有了自己的房子。”
My brother is a real estate lawyer. He owns a nice craftsman bungalow in an adjacent town. He also owns a big Edwardian mansion with leaded glass windows and a slate roof. He also owns a couple dozen other houses, and he's always buying more.
弟弟是个房地产律师。他在邻近城镇拥有一个不错的工匠平房。他还拥有一栋带铅玻璃窗和板岩屋顶的爱德华时代豪宅。他还拥有几十栋其他房子，并且一直在买更多。
He talked a while longer about how much he disliked the house, then he paused and looked up at the ceiling, which was covered with adhesive, glow-in-the-dark stars. "I put those there," he said, as though it surprised him that there'd ever been a time when he cared enough about this house to lavish glow-in-the-dark stars on it. He got a contemplative look, and I waited for him to say something heartfelt or hopeful. But he looked me in the eye and said, "I just don't think anybody has any business owning a vehicle that doesn't have a carriage-welded class four trailer hitch."
他又聊了一会儿他有多讨厌这栋房子，然后他停下来，抬头看着覆盖着粘性、夜光星星的天花板。“我把那些放在那里，”他说，仿佛他惊讶于自己曾经有足够关心这栋房子的时候，以至于在那上面挥霍夜光星星。他露出深思的样子，我等待他能说点感人或充满希望的话。但他看着我的眼睛说：“我只是不认为任何人有生意拥有一辆没有托架焊接四级拖车挂钩的车辆。”
Strange that my brother should've mentioned the possibility of my father's dying, because five days after he stopped by, I got a grim email from my father, who was still in Europe. The subject line read, "The cancer appears to be back."
奇怪的是，弟弟提到了父亲去世的可能性，因为在他来过五天后，我收到了父亲的一封阴沉邮件，他当时还在欧洲。主题行写着：“癌症似乎又回来了。”
Four years earlier, my father had learned he had non-Hodgkin's lymphoma, which he had been able to beat into remission after six unpleasant months of chemotherapy. We'd been hoping he was rid of it forever, but the day before I got the email, he checked himself into a hospital in Croatia because he was vomiting blood, and the doctor noticed a suspicious obstruction in his stomach.
四年前，父亲得知自己患有非霍奇金淋巴瘤，在六个月不愉快的化疗后，他能够将其治愈到缓解状态。我们一直希望他永远摆脱了它，但在我收到邮件的前一天，他因为吐血入住了克罗地亚的一家医院，医生注意到他的胃里有一个可疑的阻塞物。
At the house, spring was deepening into summer, and this was already a bumper year for bugs. I was pulling deer ticks off me about as often as I was brushing my teeth. I was funding them between my toes, behind my ears, all over my head, and worse places. I feared for my father's weakened immune system, and I thought the yard would need more beating back if you wanted to walk across it without risking a snake bite or Lyme disease.
在房子里，春天正向夏天深化，这是虫子丰收的一年。我每隔一会儿就会从身上拔掉鹿蜱虫，就像我刷牙一样频繁。我发现它们在我的脚趾之间、耳朵后面、整个头上，以及更糟糕的地方。我为父亲虚弱的免疫系统担心，我想如果他想走过院子而不冒险被蛇咬或患上莱姆病，院子需要更多的清理。
I decided to hold a work day. I called up my stepfather. We used to fight a good deal in my teenage days, sometimes physically and spectacularly, but since then we've come to understand each other better, and now he's someone I love and respect as much as anyone in the world. He's the kind of person who doesn't think twice about helping somebody out, even if that person happens to be his wife's ex-husband. When I asked him if he'd come and spend a day hacking vines at my father's house, he said, "Sure. What time?"
我决定举行一个工作日。我叫来了继父。我在青春期时经常和他打架，有时是身体上，非常壮观，但从那以后我们开始更好地理解彼此，现在他是我世界上最爱和尊重的人之一。他是一个不假思索地帮助别人的人，即使那个人恰好是他妻子的前夫。当我问他是否愿意花一天时间在我父亲的房子里砍伐藤蔓时，他说：“当然。几点？”
Then I called my brother "Man, I really hate going over there," he said. "I'll just have one of my guys do it." I said, "OK." But then he said, "no, I'll be there. But let's start early. Like 7 AM."
然后我叫了弟弟。“伙计，我真的很讨厌去那边，”他说。“我只会叫我的人中的一个去做。”我说，“好吧。”但他随后说，“不，我会去的。但让我们早点开始。比如早上7点。”
My stepdad showed up first, at few minutes after eight o'clock. He got to work scraping the ivy off the house with a putty knife.
继父先到了，八点多一点。他开始用油灰刀刮掉房子上的常春藤。
My brother arrived at 2 PM, seven hours late. First he filled the chainsaw's oil tank with gasoline, and it took another hour to flush the engine out and get it running again. Then he sawed into a ruined 40-foot cherry tree so firmly swaddled in the vine canopy that even when he'd severed the trunk, the tree just hung there like a toothpick in a spider's web. He hooked a rope to it and tied the other end to his carriage-welded class four trailer hitch. The tree came down with a satisfying thud.
弟弟下午2点才到，迟到了七个小时。首先他把链锯的油箱加满了汽油，又花了一个小时冲洗引擎并重新启动。然后他锯进一棵毁坏的40英尺樱桃树，它被藤蔓覆盖得太紧了，即使锯断了树干，树也像蜘蛛网里的牙签一样挂着。他挂上一根绳子，另一端绑在他的托架焊接四级拖车挂钩上。树在一声令人满意的沉闷声中倒下了。
I fired up my weed eater, which I'd outfitted with a big metal blade and charged to the vines. Some grew in braids as big around as my waist. I slashed at them. I hacked into rooms of vine, hearts of vine, giant, ventricular chambers, and then I hacked my way back out. The complexes of vine and leafage were huge, and I was tiny in their midst. I felt like a one-man cancer waging a vicious assault against this mammoth organism.
我启动了我的割草机，我给它装上了一个大金属刀片，冲向了藤蔓。有些藤蔓编成的辫子有我的腰那么粗。我猛砍它们。我砍进藤蔓房间、藤蔓中心、巨大的心室，然后我砍出一条路出来。藤蔓和叶子的复合体很大，我在它们中间显得很渺小。我觉得自己像个单枪匹马的癌症，对这个巨大的有机体发动了凶猛的攻击。
My father had returned to town a few days earlier, but I'd explained that the house wasn't quite safe for him to visit. I went out that night to meet him and his wife for dinner. He was leaving the following morning to begin treatment at a hospital in Houston. I told them about the battle we'd waged on his yard that day, and he said, "Don't do anything too drastic with those vines. They provide a nice buffer from the road."
父亲几天前已经回城了，但我解释说房子对他来说不太安全。那天晚上我出去见他和他的妻子吃晚饭。他第二天早上要走，去休斯顿的一家医院开始治疗。我告诉他们那天我们在他院子里进行的战斗，他说：“不要对那些藤蔓做太剧烈的事情。它们提供了一个来自道路的不错缓冲。”
Then my stepmother, who grew up in the Midwest, said, "I know that for Southern men, the home place is a big deal. Do you think of a house that way? As your home place?"
然后继母，在美中长大的她说：“我知道对于南方男人来说，故乡是一个大事。你把房子看作那样吗？作为你的故乡？”
I'd had a few beers at this point, and I permitted myself to say, "I don't see as a home place as much as a kind of mausoleum of embalmed grief over my parents' failed marriage." It was a cruel, self-serving thing to say, and hardly true, seeing as both my mother and father considered the divorce to be one of the best things that ever happened to them.
那时候我已经喝了几瓶啤酒，我允许自己说：“我不把这看作故乡，更多地看作是为父母失败的婚姻而埋葬悲伤的陵墓。”这是一句残酷、自私的话，而且很难说是真的，因为母亲和父亲都认为离婚是他们发生过的最好的事情之一。
My father looked very sad when I said it. But I wasn't sorry. I was simply angry at his house and at his illness, because now that the cancer was back, the dream of the two of us fixing up the place was pretty much wrecked.
当我这么说时，父亲看起来非常难过。但我并不后悔。我只是对他那栋房子和他的疾病感到愤怒，因为既然癌症复发了，我们两个一起修理这个地方的梦想基本上被摧毁了。
Here's a superficial inventory of repairs and improvements I undertook at my father's house.
这是我对我父亲房子的修理和改善的肤浅清单。
Replaced mailbox. Scattered fresh gravel on driveway. Replaced toilet. Replaced stove. Fixed refrigerator. Replumbed waste drain under kitchen sink. Bought large pickup truck and hauled about 35 truckloads of garbage to the landfill. Purged garage entirely, washed everything off, and then put everything back that wasn't broken junk. Paid over the ground laminate walls in the living room. Installed two small skylights. Chased black snake from attic. Killed black widow spider. Dragged enormous gob of hair from bath drain. Chopped a cherry tree into firewood. Chased bird from living room. Cleaned gutters. Caulked hole in the windowsill where the ants had stashed the beetle parts years back.
更换邮箱。在车道上撒了新鲜碎石。更换厕所。更换炉子。修理冰箱。重修了厨房水槽下的废水管道。买了大型皮卡车，运了大约35卡车垃圾到垃圾填埋场。彻底清理了车库，洗净一切，然后把没有损坏的垃圾放回原处。在客厅的层压板墙上铺设了覆盖物。安装了两个小天窗。从阁楼赶走了黑蛇。杀死了黑寡妇蜘蛛。从浴缸下水口拖出巨大的头发团。把樱桃树砍成柴火。从客厅赶走鸟。清理排水沟。填补了窗台上的洞，蚂蚁多年以前把甲虫碎片藏在那儿。
My girlfriend at the time called me one day to ask what I was up to, and I talked to her about my father's house. The walls I wanted to rip down, the plan I had for raising the ceilings, and how tinted stucco would probably be a nice way to cover up the ugly brick exterior.
当时的女朋友有一天打电话问我在做什么，我跟她聊了父亲的房子。我想拆掉的墙壁，我打算提升天花板的计划，以及着色的灰泥可能是覆盖丑陋砖砌外观的不错方式。
She said she got the whole project was a bad idea. Then she got sort of angry and said, "What about the house you were going to build? I think it's unhealthy for you to be putting all this energy into a house that's not even yours. That house is making you crazy."
她说她觉得整个项目是个坏主意。然后她有点生气地说：“你打算建造的那栋房子呢？我认为把所有精力投入到一个甚至不属于你的房子里，这对你来说是不健康的。那栋房子让你疯了。”
Then I got angry in return, and I said that unless she'd grown up in a house like this one, she couldn't possibly understand what working on it meant to me. Nobody had ever cared about the house. It was a dead place. And if I could bring it back to life, it would mean vanquishing a sorrow I'd carried with me for a long time. This, I told her, was way more important to me than building a house of my own. I got fierce and sincere about it, and finally she said, OK, OK, I understand.
然后我反过来生气了，我说除非她从小在像这样的房子里长大，否则她不可能理解在这上面工作对我意味着什么。从来没有人关心过这栋房子。这是一个死掉的地方。如果我能让它复活，那就意味着战胜一种我背负了很久的悲伤。我告诉她，这对我来说比建造自己的房子重要得多。我对此变得激烈而真诚，最后她说，好吧，好吧，我明白了。
I flew to Houston to take care of my father for a couple of weeks. He was well into a six month chemotherapy regimen. His hair and eyebrows had fallen out, and he walked very slowly because the cancer was eating his bones.
我飞往休斯顿照顾父亲几周。他正处于六个月化疗疗程中。他的头发和眉毛都掉光了，他走得很慢，因为癌症在吃他的骨头。
I helped him move into the apartment where he was to live between hospital stays. One afternoon, he asked me how things had been going in my life. I told him I'd been getting a lot of satisfaction out of working on his house, that there was a great deal more I'd like to do. He nodded. "Perhaps the sensible thing would simply be for you take it over," he said.
我帮他搬进他在医院留宿期间居住的公寓。一天下午，他问我生活过得怎么样。我告诉他我从修理他的房子中得到了很多满足感，还有很多我想做的事情。他点点头。“也许明智的做法是你接手它，”他说。
I thought he might say this, and when he did, I felt a warmth in my chest. I told him that I hoped he'd get better soon, and that we'd still have many years together working on the place.
我以为他会这么说，当他真的说了，我感到胸口一阵温暖。我告诉他我希望他早日康复，我们还能有许多年一起修理这个地方。
The idea seemed to cheer him. He rose gingerly and walked to the window. A storm was just departing, and rumpled, greenish clouds were sliding east over the Houston skyline. He watched them go and said absently, "Being alive sure beats being dead."
这个想法似乎让他高兴起来。他小心翼翼地站起来，走到窗前。一场暴风雨刚过去，皱巴巴的、微绿的云正向东滑过休斯顿的天际线。他看着它们离去，心不在焉地说：“活着绝对比死掉强。”
After I got back from Houston, I had a carpenter friend over, and together we walked the premises while dreamed to him about the house. "What if we put in exposed beams and then a sunroom off the garage, fruit trees in the yard, a new tin roof, wrap-around around porches, throw in a patio, put up a grape arbor for shade?" He said, "Yeah. This place could be a little palace if somebody wanted to give a damn about it."
从休斯顿回来后，我请了一个木匠朋友过来，我们一起走过房子的场地，我向他做着关于房子的梦。“如果我们装上露出的横梁，然后在车库外面装个阳光房，院子里种上果树，一个新的锡屋顶，环绕的门廊，加上一个露台，盖个葡萄架遮阴呢？”他说：“是的。如果有人想给点关心，这个地方可以成为一个小宫殿。”
I called my brother and told him what Dad and I had in mind. My taking over the house and fixing it up right. He went silent for a long time, and he said, "Yeah, I don't really see myself letting you do that." He said the house was his, too, his birthright. He reminded me that the house was on valuable land, and he couldn't comprehend why I wanted to ruin a perfectly good investment opportunity. I said I didn't want an investment opportunity. I wanted a place to live. Then I pleaded with him, then I shouted at him, then we both hung up.
我打电话给弟弟，告诉他爸爸和我脑子里想的。我接管这栋房子并把它修理好。他沉默了很长时间，然后说：“是的，我真的不认为我会让你那么做。”他说这栋房子也是他的，他的长子继承权。他提醒我这栋房子是在有价值的土地上，他无法理解为什么我想毁掉一个完美的投资机会。我说我不想要投资机会。我想要一个生活的地方。然后我求他，然后我对他大喊，然后我们都挂断了电话。
He called a week later and said, "The only thing I've been able to think about for about the past week is how good it would feel to beat your face in with a baseball bat." I told him I'd been having thoughts along the same lines, only mine involved a machete. He said, "Look. I thought it over, and if you want the house, it's yours. Take it. It's just not worth it to me. I'd rather have a brother than a piece of property."
他一周后打电话说：“过去一周我能想到的唯一事情就是，用棒球棒把你的脸打烂会感觉有多好。”我告诉他我也在想同样的事，只不过涉及的是一把砍刀。“听着。我想过了，如果你想要这栋房子，它就是你的。拿去吧。它对我来说不值得。我宁愿有一个兄弟，也不愿拥有这一份财产。”
I asked him if he meant it, and he said he did. "But before you start throwing yourself into fixing it up," he said, "I do think you ought to ask yourself, if Dad passes on, do you really want to be in that house, living with all that old junk, trapped in the house you grew up in?"
我问他是认真的吗，他说他是。“但在你开始投入修理它之前，”他说，“我确实认为你应该问问自己，如果爸爸去世了，你真的想待在那栋房子里，住在那堆旧垃圾里，困在你长大的那栋房子里吗？”
I rocked back in my chair and looked out the window. I'd washed it only last week, but already, hammocks of spiderweb were drooping in the corners of the pane. The dusk was coming on. Outside the sunlight sifted through the walls of vine and lay on the lawn in a million golden shards.
我坐在椅子里向后靠，望向窗外。我一周前才擦过它，但蜘蛛网的吊床已经垂在了窗格的角落里。黄昏即将降临。在外面，阳光透过藤蔓墙筛落，以一百万个金色的碎片躺在草坪上。
"Just talking to you as a friend," he said. "Take the house if you want to. But I'd think you'd be a lot happier if you just got out of there. If you started fresh in your own place." My room was going dark, and I felt a sadness rise, because I knew my brother was probably right.
“只是作为朋友跟你说，”他说。“如果你想要就拿走这栋房子。但我认为如果你搬出去会更快乐。如果你在自己的地方重新开始。”我的房间变暗了，我感到一阵悲伤升起，因为我知道弟弟很可能是对的。
On a frigid morning four days into my father's bone marrow transplant, some appraisers came by to assess the value of Dad's house for the purpose of squaring away estate in the event of his death. There were two of them-- a short, pudgy man with glasses wearing an Australian bush hat and a woman with a kind, dithering manner.
在父亲骨髓移植的第四个寒冷早晨，一些评估师过来评估爸爸房子的价值，目的是为了以防万一处理财产。他们有两个——一个矮胖、戴着眼镜、戴着澳大利亚丛林帽的男人，和一个举止有些迟疑的女人。
I followed them around the house as they tapped the walls and jotted down the vintages of the appliances. The woman noted the wisteria jungle, which was now a brittle, leafless tangle. "It's a constant battle with that stuff, isn't it?" she said.
我跟着他们在房子周围，他们敲击墙壁并记下电器的生产年份。那个女人注意到了紫藤丛，现在那是一堆脆的、无叶的纠缠物。“这和那些东西的战斗是持续不断的，不是吗？”她说。
The man gazed up at the gable end, where paint was flaking off. "Well," he said in a tone of forced optimism, "it's a great location, at least."
男人凝视着山墙顶端，那里的油漆正在剥落。“嗯，”他以一种强作乐观的语调说，“至少位置很好。”
They tried to take a few more measurements, which was impossible in this particular spot, because a line of scrub bushes was growing against the wall.
他们试图多做几次测量，这在这个特殊的地方是不可能的，因为一排灌木丛正对着墙壁生长。
"So what are they going to do with it?" the man asked me, as though my father were already dead. "Sell it, I guess? Split it up? The land's sure worth something." I had a strong temptation to say something unpleasant to the man, but instead I said, "We'll see."
“那么他们打算怎么处理它？”男人问我，好像我父亲已经去世了。“卖掉它，我猜？分开它？土地肯定值点什么。”我强烈地想要对这个男人说些难听的话，但相反，我说：“我们走着瞧。”
I stood and watched the appraisers leave. On his way back to the driveway, the man stopped in his tracks to examine something half-buried in the lawn-- a rusted tire iron stuck in the frozen soil. "Will you look at that," he said to his colleague. He bent over and started trying to pry it loose with his pink fingers, attempting a little improvement of his own.
我站着看着评估师离开。在回车道的路上，男人停下脚步，检查半埋在草坪里的东西——一根插在冻土里的生锈轮胎扳手。“你会看那个吗，”他对他同事说。他弯下腰，开始用粉红色的手指尝试把它撬松，尝试着他自己的小改善。
The moment gave off a rather excessive sort of significance, the wind rustling the dry vines, the winter sky the color of old bone, and the appraiser, whose valuation would come in surprisingly low, straining and grunting over this piece of humble treasure.
那一刻流露出一种过度夸张的意义，风沙沙作响吹动着干枯的藤蔓，冬天的天空有着老骨头的颜色，而评估师——他的估价竟然会出奇地低——对着这个卑微的宝藏拉紧和哼哼。
The tire iron wasn't coming free easily, and the sight of the appraiser's efforts wearied me, so I headed back inside and left him to his work.
轮胎扳手没那么容易出来，看着评估师的努力让我感到厌倦，所以我回到里面，留下他去工作。
Wells Tower. A version of his enjoy ran in the Washington Post a couple of years back. He's the author of the book of short stories Everything Ravaged, Everything Burned . It;s out in hardcover and comes out in paperback next month.
威尔斯·托尔。他文章的一个版本几年前在《华盛顿邮报》上发表过。他是短篇小说集《一切蹂躏，一切焚烧》的作者。它有精装本，下个月出平装本。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。生产帮助来自亚伦·斯科特。塞斯·林德是我们的生产经理，艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can hear all of our old shows for free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for or program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains why he is sticking with Nyquil. Lots and lots of Nyquil.
我们的网站，在那里您可以免费收听我们所有的老节目，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他解释了为什么他坚持使用Nyquil。大量大量的Nyquil。
I'm allergic to marijuana. I don't like alcohol. Crank is too intense. Heroin makes you sick. LSD is a recreational thing once in a while when you were a kid going to concerts with Mickey Mouse ears.
我对大麻过敏。我不喜欢酒精。冰毒太猛了。海洛因让你生病。LSD是一种偶尔尝试的休闲东西。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。